مع كل هزه ارتداديه جديده يشعر بها
الاتراك تهتز معها قلوب سكان هذه الاحياء
والاف من قاطني بنايات وصف عمده اسطنبول
هياكلها بالخطيره
انها مساله حياه او موت هكذا حذرت سلطات
اسطنبول سكان هنا داعيه اصحاب البنايات
الهشه والقديمه الى الاسراع في فحسها وهنا
علي تركي من اصول عربيه يعيش بهذه البنايه
المتصدعه في حي الفاتح منذ سنوات في
تشققات
الفاتح وعندي هون تشققات بس فوق وانا ما
عم بقول لك ما في خوف في خوف بس شلون
الوضع مثلا اليوم صار شيء
بره كل ما يشغل باله هذه الايام هو كيفيه
انقاذ عائلته في حال تحركت الارض
والله يسترنا اذا كان وضع مثلا بدي يهدوا
يهدوا الحكومه وانا بقرف خايف على اولادك
لكن كل واحد خايف على اولاده غير الله
سبحانه وتعالى وهالاولاد
احصت بلديه اسطنبول ما يزيد عن 100 الف
بنايه بحاجه عاجله الى فحص ضوئي واوسط
باتخاذ قرارات صارمه لانقاذ ملايين
الارواح في ظل توقعات خبراء بحدوث زلزال
هائل خلال السنوات القادمه
نحن نتوقع ان يحدث زلزال اخر قد لا يكون
مركزه في اسطنبول لكنها ستتضرر كثيرا
خصوصا اننا لم نحضر جيدا لذلك فكثير من
البنايات غير مطابقه للزلازل ويجب اعاده
النظر سريعا في معايير البناء
توقعات زادت من ارباك الناس مع تواتر
مخلفات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
البلاد
القديمه لو ازيلت لكان افضل لذلك نطالب
السلطات بالتحرك قبل فوات الاوان يعني
متعرضين اي ساعه او دقيقه
في اسطنبول يعني واذا صار في اسطنبول بده
يصير كارثه كبيره يعني عم نسهر للساعه
تنتين ليه للخوف
وامام هذا الوضع تسابق السلطات التركيه
الزمن لبحث حلول استباقيه قد تجنب البلاد
تكرار كارثه زلزال الجنوب الذي لم يتوقف
بعد عداد ضحاياه رغم تجاوزه الاربعين الف
قتيل